that is a [ __ ] ton of red bull
what is the deal with that does anyone
know
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are you doing
what
what is this
red bull
yeah
clearly
i'm a big fan are you yeah you see the
race this weekend
yeah i did we won
interesting choice of words we want yeah
we
wha
what happened in the last week that
you're
well um
after
what i said last week yeah i don't know
if you remember that yeah but i said
some
yeah you know something slightly
disparaging about the red bull car and
our agent afterwards contacted us she
said she wasn't very happy because there
could be a big opportunity to do
something
with red bull in the future and i
realized at that moment
i actually love it
oh
so did you put all this here yeah
yeah yeah yeah i love i love i drink
this i drink it all the time
oh wow oh wow that's fast
[Laughter]
it gives you wings
yeah
definitely yeah i love it i love it and
i love the f1 i love the f1
and the red bull car yeah in f1 yeah and
i love the fact that we won this weekend
let's go matt verstappen
i'm sorry did you say matt
yeah matt verstappen
the red bull driver matt verstappen he
won
i'm sure you saw don't play dumb yeah no
but his name is max that's what i said
matt's verstappen
first happened stacking
maddox for stack for a second yeah
that's what what are you saying
i'm saying it's max respect
no you just said no alex you just said
i'm sorry what's the confusion here i'm
not really following it's max verstappen
and you're saying maddox for stacking
yes
the driver of the f1 team the red bull
team
i don't did you wake up [ __ ] stupid
today or something dude
just give it a name give me the name one
more time
it's
annex misn
it's that's what's happening
you